today we're going to be speaking with Dr
Gloria Mark who's the Chancellor's
professor at the University of
California Irvine she studied attention
and stress in the digital age for over
two decades and is also author of The
forthcoming book out on Tuesday January
10th attention span a groundbreaking way
to restore balance happiness and
productivity you can find out more about
it at gloriamark.com really great having
you on I appreciate the opportunity to
talk about this thank you for helping me
so it's almost become cliche Now to
repeat some of the things that have been
written many times there's no really
such thing as multitasking what you're
doing is quickly switching between tasks
it's also you know if you want to find
uh opinions that
um social media and smartphones are
killing our attention span you can find
it but now there's the next layer which
is hey you know maybe that's not
actually true when people do these
digital detoxes they don't really seem
to have the benefits some claim you can
basically find someone making every
claim at this point in time so maybe to
start we can just zoom out a little bit
and say
over the time that you have been
studying these issues are there
definitive trends that we can
um start with about the impact of modern
media smart phone social media on
attention on stress on anxiety
yes there are so um I've been studying
this empirically for almost two decades
now let me very quickly explain how I
study attention yeah so uh you know we
started out using stop watches and
shadowing people and every time someone
switched their attention or switched
screens we would uh note that we then
later switched to computer locking
techniques which are very precise very
objective and unobtrusive so we can get
precise measures of how long exactly
people's attention is on any screen
whether it's their computer or
smartphone and we find that over the
years people's attention on any screen
has diminished their length of attention
uh and in the last uh five years or so
we find that it's gone down to about 47
seconds on average if we look at the
midpoint it's called the median that we
find that half of all of our
observations of the length of attention
is actually less than 40 seconds 40
seconds is the median that means that
people switch their attention very fast
they don't spend a lot of time on any
particular screen and we know from when
we first started measuring this that the
length of attention spans have gone down
now it sounds like that's a bad thing
but maybe that's an assumption that we
should actually try to prove in some way
right I mean one one could say okay that
that's true that's what's going on but
it's just a result of the way that the
world is it doesn't objectively mean
that there's a cost or a negative is
there a cost or a negative to that
reality yeah unfortunately there is a
cost because we find a strong
relationship between the frequency of
Shifting attention and stress so stress
goes up as attention is is shifted now
going back to years of laboratory
research in Psychology we know that when
people switch their attention when they
multitask among you know switching among
different tasks blood pressure goes up
there's a a physiological marker in the
body that also indicates that people are
under stress we also know that when
people are probed with validated uh
questionnaires about their subjective
stress their perceived stress also goes
up at times when people are are shifting
their attention multitasking fast so
there is a cost yes when we talk about
the Stress and Anxiety component it
seems important to distinguish for to
take one example to take social media on
the one hand we have these aspects of
the rapidity with which you can switch
between things when you're scrolling
social media the distractive element of
picking it up and looking at it when
maybe you should be spending an hour
consecutively working so that's one side
we then have the stuff that people like
Jonathan height and others look at more
which is the effect of the content and
does seeing people's best moments when
you're just sitting at home in your
pajamas and comparing or right there's
the content aspect when it comes to kids
in school the way that some bullying has
moved into the social media space these
are two different things how can we
distinguish the impact of one from the
impact of the other
yeah so you you would have to do some
controlled studies so you'd have to
basically give people uh
uh social media that has positive
content and then give them social media
that might have negative content and
then you look at the differences so
you're you're controlling that uh and
then there's other things you can
control too such as the length of posts
and see what impact that has but there's
absolutely uh no question that social
media is uh it's two-sided right there's
there's benefits we we can't deny that
there are benefits uh for young people
they can have they can be socially
connected to other people especially
during the pandemic right it was really
a great benefit for a number of people
not not just young people uh but of
course there is a negative side as well
as you mentioned cyber bullying there's
missing information so there's
absolutely no question that there's you
know it's a double-edged sword so if we
assume that the majority of my audience
kind of understands the the guideposts
here of the concern and of the reality
of what's going on
um let's talk a little bit about sort of
like how One what safeguards or
behaviors one can kind of cultivate for
for themselves
um Neil Postman in his book technopoly
you know like 30 years ago wrote about
uh whenever there's a new technology
there's good and there's bad the idea of
saying let's only allow the good through
regulation it rarely works and we really
just need to to kind of think through
the best way to welcome these
Technologies in total all right and and
sort of limit limit the damage that they
can do what should people be doing is it
you know practically is it you put your
phone in a different room you set a
timer and use these techniques where you
work 25 minutes I think it's the
Pomodoro Technique 25 minutes and then a
five minute break and then you switch to
something else and is that is it
practical to think people can really do
that regularly
yeah so first of all consider there are
individual differences so personality
absolutely plays a role in people's
ability to self-regulate some people are
more lucky they have good uh good
abilities for self-regulation other
people are not born some lucky but if
you're not born lucky there are things
you can do to change people can develop
agency over their behaviors and if we
draw from the work of a very famous
social psychologist Albert bandura he's
found that people in a number of areas
can develop self-efficacy so with
stopping smoking substance abuse and so
I believe that it's very possible for
people to have control over their
attention
uh how can they gain an agency there's
different ways first of all uh you can
learn to be more intentional in your
behavior so we do a lot of automatic uh
behaviors for example we check our our
smartphones you know just automatically
without thinking we check email we go to
social media
what you can do is you can learn it to
probe yourself to bring your your
unconscious actions uh to become more
conscious uh I'm a professional Observer
of people when I study them and I've
learned to become a professional
Observer of Myself by probing myself
probing the reasons why I'm doing things
so whenever I have an urge to go to
social media I recognize that urge I ask
myself will I get value out of being
there why do I have this need to go
there am I bored am I doing a hard task
right and anyone can develop this skill
to become an observer of themselves and
once you recognize reasons for why
you're doing things you can change right
and if you go to social media to take a
break then again you can probe yourself
and say am I still getting value or am I
just getting marginal returns and if
you're just getting marginal returns
it's time to get back to work uh let me
mention another uh technique that people
can do is to practice what's called
forethought forethought means imagining
your future self and it could be in the
very near future like at the end of the
day if you go on social social media now
how is that going to impact your life at
10 pm or midnight are you still going to
be working on that deadline or are you
going to be relaxing have a glass of
wine watching your favorite show think
ahead right another uh technique that
people can do is to maintain their
higher level goals in their mind goals
are a great Shield against distractions
if because because attention is directed
to what our goals are and if your goal
is that you're going to work on this
deadline and finish it right then your
attention will be directed to it
one of the people I've interviewed
before is Cal Newport who writes a lot
about carving time out for what he calls
deep work and of course at the very you
know minimum that means you're not
checking your smartphone during this
time but ideally also there you're
you're limiting other distractions in
other ways and you know we've talked
with him about that one of the things
that seems to apply in the diet world
that may also apply here is whatever
you're doing needs to be sustainable it
seems like and that's one of the better
arguments I've read against the total
sort of like uh social media
um sabbatical of sorts which is that it
creates what's really an artificial
situation that that nobody says is going
to be the long-term situation and that
therefore it might be sort of a limited
value whereas maybe there's more value
to saying hey you know I know I have a
tendency to do my best deep work in the
morning so from 9 to 11 I'm not even
gonna have my phone in the room and and
so now I'm at least getting to 11
without any distractions and then from
then on I will do X Y or Z that that
type of thing can you talk a little bit
about is it better to jump right into
modes that are sustainable long term or
do these short-term experiments have
their place
no I I don't think that realistically uh
we can think about doing digital detoxes
for a very long time you know if if any
individual does a digital detox
essentially it penalizes themselves
because they're cutting themselves off
from important work Communications from
family from loved ones and you're right
absolutely it's not sustainable we we
live in a digital world the ship has
sailed we can't back away from it we
can't pull out so what we need to do
instead is to think of solutions that uh
that can enable us to live in this world
and to maintain well-being now it turns
out that people
um you know you can't maintain sustained
Focus for a lengthy period just in the
same way that you can't lift weights for
an extended period of time we we use up
our mental resources now people have
Peaks of time during the day when their
mental resources are at their utmost
and for most people it's mid to late
morning and it's mid-afternoon if you
can become aware of when your personal
peaks of attention are
and you can start with with these times
that I mentioned uh then you can gear
your work around those times when your
attention is is at its best yeah that's
been super useful for me we're very you
know I used to have a list of things
that I sort of plan to accomplish after
taping my show each day and I learned
that I would get only to a fraction of
that list just because of sort of like
mood and who knows other things that
that maybe I can't necessarily identify
but I found that the more I plan to do
before filming each day
dramatically more efficient dramatically
more productive and so now I kind of
tail I know that if I get to my desk 15
minutes earlier I'm going to do way more
than if I think of doing that at 3 P.M
now I have the benefit of a job where
I'm completely in control of my schedule
the reality is a lot of people are
squeezing these things in around shift
work for example and that becomes very
difficult
that's right absolutely so so that's
right you know every person is different
everyone has their own personal Rhythm
uh and you need to gear your work around
what your own personal rhythm is for for
your attentional resources and you know
for me I I can't start work immediately
when I get up I I need time to ramp up
so I I do easy things when I start you
know I I will take care of email I'll
read the news and then you know I'm a
little bit geared up and then I can
start diving into doing hard work and
then I'm at my Peak now you know people
can discover their Peak by you know
finding out what your chronotype is some
people are early types some people are
light types it can serve as a guide at
least to get you started but become
aware of when you start feeling
exhausted and the best thing you can do
is pull back take a break
get replenished and then you can go back
in with with a full tank of resources we
have been speaking with Dr Gloria Mark
uh the book which is out on Tuesday
January 10th is attention span a
groundbreaking way to restore balance
happiness and productivity productivity
you can find out more at
www.gloriamark.com really appreciate
your time and your insights today
thank you so much for having me